[موسيقى
] سبب إطلاقنا هو
واحد من ثلاثة أسباب تفرض
زخمًا هائلاً مع الحساب والإبداع ،
ومن الواضح أن هذا
أمر رائع بالنسبة لنا لرؤية
مساحة YouTube نفسها تُظهر
التزامنا تجاه المنطقة لأن
هذا  ليست مساحة منبثقة ، إنها
مساحة دائمة أعتقد أن هناك
الكثير من الفكاهة التي يتم استخدامها في
الشرق الأوسط وأعتقد أنها رائعة
لأنها تعني أن الناس يحبون الضحك ، فإن الكثير من
الكارهين لديهم هدايا من كل ذلك خلق
مساحة دعابة على YouTube  من خوسيه
ولعبتهم المسرحية للمانجو ولم أقتله ،
حسنًا ، روكفلر هنا ماهاكالي
سولومونوف حظًا صغيرًا ، لقد حصلنا على أخصائي أنابيب جديد
أو إلكترونًا وتوفي هل
أصبت وجهك بالطريقة التي كان لها
وجه جميل و YouTube لا  مجرد
صورة ذاتية مع الكيان راهول جزيرة
مع كل الأمريكيين الذين صُدموا
بسبب وجودهم في الفضاء لماكان الذي
تلقيحهم على YouTube